within the confines of the lands between
there are races seemingly created by
higher beings
be it outer gods gods or even the
crucible but there is a race whose
origins were created by humans whose
fate is to be downtrodden whose lives
are some of the worst within the lands
between
they are known as albinorics
as with most of our videos let us start
with the question
what are the albanorics
the albinorics are creatures supposedly
created by humans due to this it is
believed that they are untouched by the
earth tree's grace
and their bodies come with defects that
make their life difficult to say the
very least
these defects depend highly on many
factors but the most important one is
whether they are the first generation
albanoric or the second
first generation abenorics lose usage of
their legs within their lifespan but
they seem to be more intelligent than
their second generation counterparts
they are able to exhibit impressive bow
techniques and though they lose their
legs the archers are able to bond with
wolves in order to make up for their
lack of movement other albanorics are
even able to use basic sorcery such as
glintstone pebble and there are npcs we
meet and help that are first generation
albinorics these include characters like
latina and pedia who we'll talk about in
a bit
meanwhile their second generation
counterparts are far more agile these
frog-faced albinourics are capable of
wielding bigger weapons their signature
move is to
cartwheel around their enemies though we
don't meet any second generation
albenoric with a storyline i did manage
to find one that is a bit different from
the rest but again we'll tackle that in
a bit for now let us speculate on where
these albanorics may have come from
it is unknown who truly created the
albinorics and whether those that
created the first generation and the
second generation are one in the same
but there are already many speculations
on who might have created them let's
break down each one of these possible
candidates
first and the most speculated one is the
nox or the eternal cities
it is believed that albinourics might be
another version of the silver tiers
either a better version or a weaker
version probably weaker though
this belief is born from the idea that
both the silver tears and the albinorics
are born from silver
they even share the same white blood
when you strike them the first
generation albanorics also use silver
weapons and silver armor which is said
to have come from the same silver that
was the mother of the albanorics
the silver tear mask and the second
generation albinoric mask both increase
arcane and there are many more
similarities between them
in line with this theory is that the
reason why the albanorics are untouched
by the grace of the earth tree is that
they were created in order to oppose the
golden order is this proof that the knox
created the albanorics maybe but we
don't have any real confirmation
another candidate for the ones who
created the albinorics are the carrion
royals
this belief stems from pedia who is a
servant within the carrion royal manor
as well as the abenorics village being
in close proximity to raya lucaria
academy in lyrnia
though to be honest it's also somewhat
close to the eternal cities they're just
underground
this theory is also supported by factors
such as the weapons of the albinourics
being shaped as a crescent moon and the
abanark's most vaunted savior lorena
knight of the heilig tree was formerly a
knight of the carrion royals
their origin may also be related with
the amber egg that ranala holds as it
may be one of the possible origins of
the albanorics it is said that
albanorics are born from a primordial
drop of dew the shape of which is
imitated by the silver mirror shield and
that the shield is adorned by amber this
could potentially point to the amber
egg's ability to birth and rebirth
creatures and the albinorics may have
been a product or a byproduct of such
birth i mean those born from the amber
egg also have weak legs that they are
unable to walk
but they have red blood so they may not
be of the same stock as the albinorics
but again as with the other theory we
have no real confirmation of this these
two theories could be the origins of the
albino orcs for me personally though i
think it's a little bit of both ronnie
is familiar with the eternal cities so
the carrion royals could have gotten
information from their studies of them
and thus created their own form of
artificial life but with the oppression
of the albinorics they would eventually
turn against their sorcerer masters
hence why their armor and shields
protect mostly against magic and frost
but whether these are true or not i
leave it to you to decide
let me tell you of the difficulties of
the albenorics and of those who fight
for their future of their perilous
journey to a land where they'd be free
of suffering to michela's hailing tree
the albanorics have always been treated
as nothing but slaves and experiments
this is most evident within the volcano
manor the albanorics here may have been
under the employ of reichard before his
turn to blasphemy
but after which they became nothing more
than a torturous plaything
this was the immovable fate of all
albanorics
but this was a fate that the royal
knight loretta wished to change
with the fall of the carrion royals and
the knights falling into disarray
loretta would leave the manor leaving
only a spell to keep the manor from
being taken by any invaders
a spell that was potent enough to ward
off the knights of cuckoo's invasion
there was a rumor that loretta was an
albanoric herself but it is never
confirmed if it is true
i personally am on the belief that it is
true a rare albanoric who possessed the
strength to help her own kind
though her legs may have failed her she
would instead ride a mighty steed and
like the other albinorics she excelled
in her archery through her capabilities
she sought to find a place where the
albinourics would be free from the
oppression they receive
she and those able-bodied albinorics
would travel far north to the hidden
lands of the heilig tree
a land where those who have no place in
the lands between are welcome
under the banner of unalloyed gold
within the service of lord mikala
loretta would be able to secure passage
and a place for the albanorics but for
reasons unknown she could not journey
herself to retrieve her fellows
instead this task was given to a young
albanoric named latina and from the
consecrated snow fields she would
journey to lyrnia towards the village of
the albinorics
the tennis goal within the village would
be an item known as the birthing droplet
likely an item that is akin to the
primordial jew to which the albanorics
were created from
it was likely safeguarded within the
village to ensure the future of their
people should loretta's quest have
failed but now that it had succeeded the
droplet must now be transported to the
hailing tree
however their journey does not go as
planned the village is attacked by ensha
who was under the employ of the all
hearing one or the tarnished known as
serginian ofnir
together with a depraved perfumer and an
open killer ansha would lay waste to the
village killing many and driving those
that survived to utter madness
all in an attempt to acquire a sacred
medallion that would lead them to
michela's hailing tree
lieutenant would flee from the village
and hide within a cave but she would be
followed by ensha in a bloodhound night
where her wolf lobo would be killed
seeing she did not have the medallion on
her they leave her alive probably to
extract information later on as without
her wolf she could go nowhere
as a side note i don't know if this is
an oversight or
something intentional but the corpses
within this village are
commoners and not albinorics if you
attack them they bleed red instead of
white
so i'm not sure if this was intentional
that
the albanorics and the village bleed red
or
if maybe their blood doesn't turn white
until later on in their life but
i'm stumped on this one
this is where we the tarnished who would
be lord would come in
armed with information from a finger
reader we would know where to find the
albanoric who wielded michela's favor
within a pot we would find old albus
as per the instruction of the finger
reader we take pity on him and he
entrusts the first half of the medallion
to us
but whether by injuries or simply the
end he would perish before us
leaving us questioning where the other
half could be
upon defeating ensha and confronting
gideon though he would tell us to seek
latina within the lakeside cave
and when we meet her she would
understandably be angry
but after showing her the medallion and
explaining the situation she would come
to trust us
and she asks that we do her a great
service of escorting her back to the
consecrated snow fields
in exchange she would tell us the
location of the second half of the
medallion
as the brave tarnish that we are we
accept her offer and journey towards the
second half of the medallion towards
castle seoul
now oddly enough there are albanorics
within the castle soul but all of them
have been driven mad and seem to have
been tortured they are used as an alarm
system at which the ghosts of the
knights of seoul would appear
but after exterminating this area of the
ghost and its commander we would find
the second half of the medallion here at
the top of the castle
upon reaching the consecrated snow
fields latent would beckon us to go past
the town of ordina
towards the apostate derelict and within
we would find an albinouric who towers
over them
one who is named philia and within her
lateness surrenders the birthing droplet
oh young yet towering sister of arse
let the birthing droplet in
and create life
for us
for all the albanorics
thank you
i finally fulfilled my purpose
our young yet towering sister will give
us hope now that nothing is left
unfinished
i will join you in battle to the bitter
end
and when the fighting is done
then you may lay me to rest
beside lobo my dear wolf
this would probably ensure the future of
the albinorics within the town of
hordina
but this is not the end of their story
aside from the abenoric archers within
the town of ordina
traversing through the hailing tree and
looking around you would find no
albanorics within
even after defeating the royal knight
loretta and after reaching the depths of
the haley tree you would not find the
albanorics
however you would discover the truth the
young lord mikala was no longer there
while the albanorics had hoped to find
salvation through lord mykola the young
imperian would be taken away by mog the
lord of blood
he paved his way through the town of
ordina carrying the young mykhila we
could follow the route that he took and
we would find those who had witnessed
the taking
we would even be invaded by one of his
sanguine nobles and upon reaching the
bloody portal headed towards his dynasty
we would find a single second generation
albinoric who had stayed behind
seemingly waiting for his people to come
back
this albunoric is a little different
from the usual second generations that
we see as this one is capable of casting
the discus of light incantation
perhaps it already had learned it from
its time within the heilig tree or
perhaps his faith towards lord mikola
had grown enough to be able to draw his
incantations
after entering the bloody portal and
arriving within the maguin dynasty we
find many albinorics here
it is likely that they had followed mog
here in order to save lord mikhala but
their bodies seem to have been changed
corrupted by the blood of the formless
mother it is unknown whether these
albinourics are still here to truly save
mykola
or perhaps they are now here to serve
the lord of blood under the promise of
new power
as the tarnished who would be lord
would the albinorics have a place in
your world would you come to the aid of
the downtrodden and the meek or would
you continue their cycle of suffering